le droit de cuissage ça rien à voir avec
la cuisse de la demoiselle
même avec les deux le droit de cuissage
c'est le droit de la cuisson du pain
alors chez nous comme partout on disait
que quand on faisait cuire les tours de
main les grosses miches de pain qui
pesait 12 kilos autrefois des très gros
phares profonds ont payé un droit quand
on utilisait un four qui était pas le
fou qu'on avait chez soi et l four du
avoue four du village ont payé un droit
ça se comprend d'ailleurs s était ce
droit de l'enfant nous dirions de
puisage du pain mais au moyen âge on
disait qu'ils sachent c'était un droit
de cuissage
et puis dans les livres d'histoire ban à
tortiller ça de façon à en faire quelque
chose qui fait bien rire le monde ce qui
est complètement idiot vous trouverez
jamais un seigneur qui allie des tordus
n'avait bougé avec toutes les filles de
son village vous imaginez si l'on
mariait sinon marié 7 samedi dans
caritas qu'il aurait été dimanche matin
essayez plus aisé de comprendre ce genre
de choses janet mais c'est exactement
comme tout ce qu'on a pu raconter les
seigneurs qui faisait pas trop l'eau des
étangs pour que les grenouilles chante
pas parce que ça troubler son sommeil je
suis c'était sept absents des choses qui
sont absolument farfelues